uh Representative Keith Keith self is a
Republican
he represents the area that uh suffered
this terrible terrible shooting Allen
Texas and he was actually asked on CNN
what about all these people who just say
thoughts and prayers that doesn't work
and he said oh yeah it does you just
have to believe in the power of God what
explain that to me Keith listen to this
now you know Congressman that is a
common refrain after these incidents
after mass shootings but many people
argue that prayers aren't cutting it
prayers are not preventing the next mass
shooting I wish she said she said rather
than many people argue just prayers
don't prevent mass shootings when you
say many people argue it's like well but
many people argue that they do no it's
just prayers don't prevent mass
shootings and yet it's all you're
willing to offer listen to this what is
your
believe in An Almighty God who who has
who is absolutely
in control of Our Lives I'm a Christian
I believe that he is oh we have people
though with mental health that we're not
taking care of since this nation made
the decision that we were going to close
the mental health institutions uh many
of these situations are based on that uh
and the people that say and and I really
I would like to stay away from the
politics today because I want to focus
on the victims right except the problem
is
right-wingers who want to do nothing
always want to stay away from the
politics they are the political problem
right it's it's it's it's almost a sick
joke to say listen this is not about
guns this is about we need mental
institutions which were horrifying by
the way many of the ones that closed
were horrifying I've been reading a book
about it in fact worst conditions
nobody's getting cured at those places
um and but but prayer works but let's
not like get all political I want to
take the politics out of it we could
take the Paul politics out of it if we
just did what the American people agreed
should be done five of the 10 or 12
things that I've outlined before
he makes the political issue a necessity
because he and many of his party say we
don't need anything other than prayer
and I guess mental institutions today
we should be focused on the families oh
uh prayer is powerful in the lives of
those people that are devastated I know
people says who I want to make this
political but prayers are important and
they are powerful in the families who
are devastated right now that may or may
not be
it is completely compatible to say
prayer may be a soothing tool for
victims or it may not it's up to them
but it has nothing to do with what civil
government must do about this Scourge or
scourge of gun violence depending on
Whose pronunciation you prefer
these can be two different things but
prayer from elected officials certainly
can't be considered policy remember when
a few weeks ago people were furious with
me because I said hey guys if you need
any more evidence that prayer doesn't
work it's that people were shot up at a
Christian School where they presumably
pray all the time and people were mad at
me oh David that's so insensitive you
christian-hating Jew bastard we've got a
lot of those
um how dare you blame the kids
folks the prayer doesn't work that's the
problem whoever thought it did they were
wrong it's not the kids this is really
the offensive thing to say you've just
got to believe in An Almighty God who
controls everything and think of that if
you truly and literally believe
that a God is in charge of the minutia
of everything including mass shootings
why would you legislate anything and
that's the danger that you have to
really understand if we believe Keith
self is literally representing his views
now the prayer is what we need because
God is in control of everything
then of course they're not going to do
anything legislatively they don't think
they have to because God has already
decided how many shootings there are or
aren't going to be and who's going to
survive or die it's a cop-out to do
nothing which is exactly what they've
done so that works really well for them